what is acid rain acid rain is any form
of precipitation with high levels of
nitric and sulfuric acids it can occur
in the form of snow fog and even dry
materials that settle to earth most acid
rain is caused by human activities when
people burn fossil fuels sulfur dioxide
and nitrogen oxides are released into
the atmosphere
these gases react with water oxygen and
other substances to form sulfuric and
nitric acid winds may spread these
acidic solutions over hundreds of miles
after it falls to earth
acid rain enters water systems as runoff
and sinks into the ground
this can make water toxic to prey fish
clams fish and other aquatic animals the
rest of the food chain including non
aquatic species such as birds is often
affected as well as a drain also harms
forests by damaging trees leaves robbing
the soil of essential nutrients and
making it hard for trees to take up
water by designing cleaner power plants
and using fewer fossil fuels
we can reduce the number of pollutants
that create acid rain
[Music]
[Music]